look right now while you looking at this
on your screen in your hand or on your
computer there's somebody just like you
who's sitting in a prison cell and they
didn't do much more than you did you
know some crazy weekend you didn't get
caught they got caught and they can
never get uncaught the United States of
America is now the number one
incarcerate er of human beings in the
world in the history of the world
we have about 5% of the world's
population we have 25% of the world's
prisoners we are what we have more
people locked up than China
China who has a billion people they got
fewer prisoners than we do you know a
lot of times people say well if you
don't want to do the time don't do the
crime really have you have you ever
committed a crime you got people who are
doing more drugs in on college campuses
and yacht clubs country clubs we all
know that's going on but the SWAT team
never shows up there the SWAT team shows
up in the housing projects where you got
poorer people doing fewer drugs and
those people go to prison but think
about it what if one of the times when
you were breaking the law when you had
something illegal in your pocket in your
car and your party the police are kicked
in those doors would you want to be
known for the rest of your life based on
what happened that night that is what is
happening to millions of people if rich
folks kids get in trouble they go to
rehab poor folks can't get in trouble
they go to prison and you spend a
hundred thousand dollars per year per
kid to lock a kid up when you could have
spent a fraction of that and turn them
into a NASA scientist turn them into a a
fashion icon when people come home from
prison they're not given the opportunity
to start over you leave a physical
prison and you go into a social prison
where you can't get a job you can't get
a student loan
you can't written up rent an apartment
how are people supposed to start over
and what happens to neighborhoods when
you take a disproportionate number of
people out
for minor offenses and you send them
back home with no hope and no
opportunity there are no more excuses to
have this horrible system continued when
there is now finally bipartisan
agreement that it is a tragedy to do
this not only do you have President
Obama and the Democrats you now actually
have a people like Paul Ryan Koch
Industries Newt Gingrich all saying the
same thing we are locking up too many
people
we're wasting too much money we're
wasting too much genius in America and
it's time to do something